alors merci sylvie d'être là savaient
qu'en février loana est malheureusement
hospitalisé après avoir fait une
overdose de médicaments airs il accuse
alors sylvie être derrière tout ça de
d'être une mauvaise personne personne
néfaste pour loana durant les jours qui
suivent les choses s'enveniment entre
les deux jusqu'à ce fameux de mars date
à laquelle nous les avons invités sur le
plateau pour faire un point sur cette
histoire et ça a été ça est un énorme
clash sur le plateau vous rasant
rappelait alors juste vous savez vous
avez deux enveloppes je te pardonne uni
comme hook
je veux me tourner vers vers sylvie
sylvie est ce que toi tu es prête à
pardonner à erin
c'est kirill alors c'est la personne ici
assez
alors déjà je voulais te souhaiter bon
anniversaire à piper des
bas et je tends pas si parce que j'ai
suivi à gta tous ses concerts qu'il
avait prévu cet été oui donc j'ai fait
le hérie le prière tour mais non mr
manitou c'est génial ce jour avec vidéo
pré flop et laisser parler c'est bon ça
c'était sublime je me suis éclaté tout
l'histoire était complet alors est ce
que vous pourriez pardonner irene est
d'ailleurs à cannes il a fait un tabac
sourire il voit ce que vous pouvez me
pardonner un site vie commenté commence
là ça va être dur en a pris un coup de
vieux
la moto le casque
elle a la banane là je crois qu'il ya
une perte de cheveux tu as tout mis
devant et aux pcb six mois pas compris
mon idole et auquel va te faire les
courses ici le tueur
[Applaudissements]
john ball
ils tuent mal de questions avec ou en
attaque elles physique que parce que
pour beaucoup d'un groupe les
réseaux moi ma vie
[ __ ] j'aurais vraiment faim
j'aurais vraiment envie
il m'a dit que
ça va bien
la chose a dit du commerce regarde le
ton tuer
leur âge
scheer et qu'on était là
mon physique jeu rapide à la grèce c'est
quoi j'aime attaquer sur mon fils joue
bana
ok on arrête ça j'aimerais qu'on vienne
vraiment
très serré on est là pour vous
réconciliez
vous savez mal démarré je suis d'émoi
chez moi chez moi je suis pas là et
convaincre qui que ce soit d'accord elle
commence à m'attaquer sur mon physique
je parle
j'ai pas attaquer sur physique les deux
les deux à la suppression non non moi je
suis pas là pour convaincre qui que ce
soit non mais ce que vous avez envie au
moins de bruit aussi avec loana vous
l'aimiez louana c'était votre ami vous
étiez très bien pour l'instant je papa
de loana n'est pas la lâcher cette
personne en face de moi que j'ai vu
quatre fois dans ma vie la fin c'est la
quatrième fois du manioc vous bon c'est
que ces morts donc la régulation est ce
qu'on peut dire à loana de venir à la un
homme et moi dit mais c'est direct
regarde tiens toi voilà à qui sait ni
coups crachats as tu n'y connais que je
sais pas qui a hérissé noël ces
nouvelles batteries on a compris et
rilos illenoo m haies mais pense
qu'elles lui même aime pas dans mes plus
profonds cauchemar rien du tout car
c'est bon c'est tout pour moi il
n'existe pas on m'a assez bon face à
genk ont
retenu notre attention
je tourne en bas ça hot shots